gefühlt gerade jede woche irgendwo auf
der welt ein neuer protest aus es ist
offensichtlich wir leben in tagen des
zorns
[Musik]
wir fragen uns in der aktuellen ausgabe
was ist eigentlich los in der welt woher
kommt diese ganze gut in einem
wohlhabenden und freien land wie in
deutschland es ist schwer vorstellbar
dass menschen ihr leben riskieren um
verbesserungen zu bewirken
in vielen anderen ländern dieser welt
ist das aber längst alltag da riskieren
die menschen ihr leben
unsere korrespondenten kennen die lage
in konfliktherden sehr genau
friederike böge war in den letzten
monaten immer wieder in hongkong wo sich
die gewalt mehr hochschaukelt brüderle
reist in lateinamerika gerade quasi vom
protestzug protest und reiner herrmann
der fünf seit vielen jahren aus den
arabischen ländern berichtet hat die
umbrüche hautnah miterlebt die jetzt zur
eskalation führen
[Musik]
zusammen haben wir uns in unserer
titelgeschichte gefragt ist es zufall
dass gerade in vielen ecken der welt
gleichzeitig proteste auf brannten oder
steckt etwas größeres dahinter erleben
wie hier vielleicht so etwas wie den
anfang einer globalen bewegung für
demokratie und freiheit
die antwort lesen sie in der faz woche
nehmen sie sich die zeit